the presidential contest might have gone
to an unprecedented second round but the
end result wasn't really in any doubt at
least not amongst these his most Ardent
supporters
it was very good where we was we are so
happy because we are waiting his win and
we are so happy why are you so happy
because our economy was good in last two
years it was not good but we know that
we trust him he's going to do his best
those celebrating here included many
women and religious conservatives a
section of the electorate he's
deliberately appealed to in contrast to
his more secular leaning rival
and as erdogan begins his third decade
in power he called it a new era for
turkey
I thank each member of our nation for
entrusting me with the responsibility to
govern this country once again for the
upcoming five years
and with that the closest challenge so
far to his rule ended it had been headed
by camel glitch deroli who clearly felt
the votes had been manipulated against
him and the millions who wanted change
this was the most unjust election
campaign ever the opposition reader said
as he conceded he lost foreign
[Music]
's Triumph has confounded his critics
coming despite a spiraling economy and
the Lira hitting a record low against
the dollar just days ago and most voters
we spoke to worried about the rampant
inflation
I can't make a living anymore
the turbulent economy has made millions
of refugees in the country especially
vulnerable with the use of inflammatory
rhetoric during the campaigning by both
candidates
syrians will go this opposition
billboard vowed the specified in an
Istanbul Factory a few days ago ended up
with the young Syrian worker being
killed his family believed it was
because he was Syrian and with the newly
re-elected President also promising to
return syrians across the border they're
all fearful now and yeah I could have
died in Syria or had to fight that's why
I chose to leave and come to Turkey but
now it feels like Wars started here Wars
are not only fought with guns sometimes
it's done with words
erdogan headed into this election on the
back of an earthquake disaster
exacerbated by the slow official
response and amid corruption accusations
the economic figures have worsened if
anything since
yet he continued to do far better than
most predicted prompting unproven
allegations of cheating by some
they stole our votes he tells us don't
say that his friend cautions him but
that's what I think he replies
turkey's position in the world
straddling East and West is uniquely
important and the influences leader has
exerted in the past over key events like
the Ukraine Russia war and European
migration has been crucial what happens
here really matters globally
[Music]
but as his loyalists celebrated those
who yearned for change were noting that
the odds were stacked against any
erdogan rival after two decades of
consolidating his position and ensuring
a mostly compliant state-controlled
media these people are Delirious with
delight but erdogan's
down on descent his jailing of
opposition politicians and journalists
and there will be many who fear that
this extension of his power is likely to
lead to more authoritarian rule but
right now the focus for his loyalists is
very much on celebrating his historic
electoral success with an enormous
Victory party gathering in Ankara where
their leader traveled to thank the huge
crowds gathered in his honor who are
going to be emboldened to take on the
new leader right now